before this video begins it's time for
me to flex on you kids
that's right i have the new honor 8x a
very nice
a very good i love the look and feel of
this phone it feels very
premium very minimalistic aesthetic
design i i really like it it's very cool
look at that
look at that shine wow look honestly
look at that if that's not epically i
don't know what it is
it has great value and low pricing it's
very impressive what they pulled off
with this phone it has a very big
display
6.5 inch with 91 screen to body ratio so
it's big it's very big it also has this
ai
camera highly intelligent so if i point
it at something it will change the
settings to
what it's looking at so now it's looking
at nine year olds and
if i do this it notices it's a face and
it changes to portrait
so it you can take really professional
photos with it because of that
i've taken some really cool photos with
it i love it and uh yeah if you guys are
interested in it check out the link in
the description for more information
from the honor official forums
or and you could also win one if you
check out the link
so do that enjoy the video back to pewds
from the future
q a time q and a time
[Music]
welcome to q a the thing that youtubers
do when they're completely out of ideas
of what they're gonna make it's
literally the bottom of the barrel
of whatever content you can make that's
right worse than you laugh you lose
now for real i i haven't done a q a in
uh when was the last time honestly
three years ago so i asked on twitter
ask me stuff and i will answer so here
we go
how the frick do you manage thank you
for censoring i appreciate it
to upload a video daily i mean i
literally watch you every day
so i guess it's bros like me who
encourage this madness i really enjoy it
it's uh
it's fun to have a goal for set for you
every day too
today i'm gonna make a video no matter
what
no matter what happens you know things
happen
undoubtedly but i always have that goal
i'm gonna get a video done
and that keeps me uh keeps me on my toes
to keep me interested that's the long
answer
short answer i have editors where the
frick
did michael the romanian go back to
romania
where he belongs how were you able to
portray a real oh wow really deep
questions here guys
a realistic version of yourself on
youtube a website which seems to reward
individuals who portray a completely
different version of themselves
than reality and what gave you the
confidence to continue to do
instead of giving in question mark ask
pewd
um i don't think it's in
until recently where i fully embraced
just
being as honest as i can be on
youtube and i think yeah you are right
and wrong
i guess here's the thing people are
smarter than you think people have
noticed i think that i've been trying to
be more honest in my videos
and open about who i am and what i'm
actually thinking
and that has just been welcomed with
open arms i think people
really do appreciate honesty it's the
kind of thing that i'm
driven towards with other youtubers as
well i want to watch
people who i think are authentic
and real and not just some version of
what they
think their audience wants to see do you
have anything to say
after ethan accused you of throwing him
under the bus on the whole better health
thing i replied live's video
just because everyone's asking so much
about this it always seems like there's
some
fan drama between me and ethan but uh
between us personally uh there's no bad
blood
yeah when will you stop stealing my
videos
when will you stop stealing mine any day
i upload a video this where do you see
yourself and youtube in 10
years well hopefully i'm in japan
other than that i don't know do you
think you'll be doing youtube your whole
life
how would i know do you think you will
do anything your whole life stop
asking me this deep questions i remember
six years ago
i thought okay maybe if i'm lucky i can
do another year
or maybe two years of youtube the
lifespan of a youtuber a few years ago
was so quick most early youtubers
they they're not making videos anymore
that's just the case so i was constantly
following the path of other youtubers
before i was
uh where i am today but now i kind of
had to set my own path
and it's been going well so far i'm
happy that i'm still able to make videos
i don't know book literature club when
ask you um
i'm sorry i know i haven't been doing uh
book review
i i've been reading a ton though i've
been reading just as much as i
normally would do so it's not like i
haven't done that so i can't make them
it's more the fact that i felt
like the videos were a little bit it was
just me summarizing the video
because that's all i had time for i
didn't really have time to dwell
any deeper with any any of the books
at least some of them i did it just felt
very shallow
and it just felt like no one's reading
these books anyway
what's the point i'm just spoiling the
plot for everyone
it just felt stupid i felt like uh who
cares
i want to figure out a better format
where it can be more engaging with you
guys
because i do want more people to join in
and actually join on the literature club
i think that could make it way more
interesting and i need to figure out a
way to do that
so that's why i haven't been doing it
but then again maybe that's what people
want you know maybe people just want me
to
talk about books i don't know what's the
meaning of life
deep questions to rid yourself from all
the suffering oh yeah is scare pewdiepie
season 2
coming or no probably not probably not
most likely not i kind of given up on
trying to push for it
the thing is i had a it was a nightmare
to record but i still have so many great
memories from it and that's
i'm still glad i had those you know are
you going to make videos with jack and
mark in the future
when we did that one video together
which was really popular
um if we get a chance to i'm i'm down
why is this little break so damn long
when when was that
inside me playing meta girl sorry ah
stop stop holding me accountable
i'm really bad marcy i can agree she she
if she's watching she's nodding her head
right now because
if i stop doing something for a while
even if i enjoyed it
i don't want to go back into it whenever
me and marcia watch
tv shows and we haven't watched one in a
while i'm like ah that show sucked
and she's always like no you really
enjoyed it
no i didn't are you going to cross the
bridge again
jesus christ yes okay you gotta face
your fears
you gotta man up and get back on that
horse so yes i will cross the bridge
again
yes i will beat the horse whatever the
expression is
how do you find cool clothing brands ask
might say two please well marta isn't
here just
just look online there's so much great
stuff online so many great websites
i'm i'm looking at clothing almost every
single day it's just something i enjoy
now
it's really weird i never thought i
would say that will the book club ever
come back
yes it will when i figure give me
suggestions
give me ideas of what i can do to make
it more interactive
i was thinking maybe i should do a
subreddit or something like that so i
can actually get your comments about it
uh maybe some video responses i don't
know who will be the best man
at your wedding i don't know edgar
this is a great q a i don't know what
was your favorite game when you were a
kid
star fox 64. it depends how young i am
it's kind of in stages you know when i
was really young
pokemon blue when i was younger than
that it was like
donkey kong country and then after that
it's probably like
world of warcraft or star fox 64. oh my
god
yeah that game was amazing just
discovering the new
paths it blew my mind then i got into
mmos i played so much tibia and so much
world of warcraft
hi felix what kind of music do you
listen to i've been listening non-stop
drain gang and
i feel like i'm going crazy because it's
all i listen to
would you consider doing another closet
tour please
i really been wanting to do one but in
my last closet video
i went all preaching be like ah you
don't have to spend a lot of money on
clothings
oh i don't i don't buy expensive watches
i'm sorry i'm a hypocrite is there a
type of video that you really like to
try making
yes there is one i've been trying to
make for weeks but i haven't been able
to find a boat i need a boat to make it
happen
hey felix do you plan on making any more
videos on whiskey
no because i did japanese whiskey irish
whiskey
scotch and bourbon so i felt like i kind
of did already
i'm also taking a break on drinking in
general
i kind of was getting a little i liked
my whiskey a little
just a little too much i feel like now
it
i'm trying to make i'm what i'm getting
almost 30 now i'm getting old guys
i'm trying to make decisions now that i
will benefit from in the future
are you a vegetarian what is all these
food questions okay no do you think i'm
a soy boy
are there any means for you took the
decision good
good sentence there mult multi and boy
are there any means for you to took the
decision to not review because you love
them too much
yes yes there has been and i'm not gonna
mention them do you play games privately
anymore it seems like you're not really
a gaming guy
anymore i still really care about gaming
culture
i still care about what games and what's
happening in the industry
but uh i don't really play that much
games anymore
and i don't know if that's a you know i
never thought i would get to that point
i always thought
i'm gonna love video games for the rest
of my life but maybe
maybe it will come back maybe it's just
a thing that goes in um
in waves there are a few games i
genuinely want to play like
games that i haven't played yet you know
silent hill 2 is
one of those classic horror games that
i've actually never played
um i really want to play persona 4. so
there are games i do want to play just
for myself i just haven't had the time i
i'm spending most of my days just
reading right now at least i feel like i
get
so much more out of reading a book than
playing a video game
it sounds like such a forced adult thing
to say but it's true
it's such a much more for me at least
satisfying
experience to read a book you made books
and video games would you ever consider
you're making your own tv show
scare pewdiepie huh we're scared
where is scare pewdiepie do you watch
pewdiepie unfortunately yes
i i do i really enjoy my videos plus i
feel like i have to watch through them
it's weird i know a lot of youtubers i
don't watch their own videos
and i always felt like if i don't even
enjoy my own videos how can i expect
other people to enjoy them so
i think if i'm not enjoying the video
that's a good sign for me to maybe
try and do something different when will
you get married hashtag ass beauty
hopefully uh some
sometime next year okay can you please
bring back the tsukebiat cash some of us
really wanted them
we already brought them back once they
were out but the image zone looked
suspicious to bring dials where there's
real or a basic black cap with basic
editing
what do you mean also sweaters and
hoodies would be amazing
well there will be sweaters and hoodies
for the next thing i'm working on i'm
making it right now uh it's still very
much work in progress but i think it's
gonna be really cool
i really really really really enjoy
designing the merch myself and i think
that
it makes it more authentic to my brand
and uh it's
really cool to see you guys wear it as
well
it's something i'm actually proud to see
other people wear thank you guys for
supporting the merch i really really
appreciate it
how are you doing are you feeling more
less stressed
nowadays way less stress than i used to
be
i had way too many things going on as
opposed to
last year or two years ago i was trapped
in so many projects like the tv shows
and
the businesses and all that stuff and i
realized i don't want to do any of this
so
i'm thrilled to just be where i am right
now i've i've been
a little bit more stressed really
because the videos i've been doing have
been more controversial
and uh it's harder it's weird i haven't
messed up yet but i'm always like okay
i don't want to mess up i i want to make
sure i do this right
and when you talk about controversial
topics or
uh these things it's so easy to mess up
it's so easy to say something that can
be interpreted the wrong way
or something that uh didn't come across
the right way and
uh you really really really really got
to be careful i never know
until i've seen the reaction so that
kind of makes me nervous sometimes
if the board members of youtube took a
collective vote and decided to make
you what would be your top most priority
changes
i think youtube's biggest problem is
that no one really
respects the website a lot of the
decisions
and changes hasn't been connected with
the community the website is great i
mean i survived the adpocalypse
it's ads are totally fine now things are
definitely
things are definitely a lot better it's
still worse but it's still a lot better
than it used to be
i guess you can say i survived the
adpocalypse so
but yeah youtube definitely i would try
to make
because that's all i'm good at really i
think making a better connection with
the people that actually use your site
and gaining back their respect
i think they've done a lot that is
really great but a lot of times it goes
unnoticed because of this
so people just focus on the negative
general question but i always wonder if
you travel the world
for some sort of tour like would you
perform or just travel
for meets and greet to me people just
traveling for
no offense no offense to
anyone but just traveling to do a tour
is ridiculous like why
why would i do that i don't care about
attention
i i feel like youtubers i do that just
really desperately want to be validated
which is fine i guess that's a great way
to do it but and even then a tour like
what would i do
the thing is i upload videos daily i
would either have to take time off just
to go on tour
i think touring makes sense for people
that maybe don't upload very frequently
and uh they can be busy
doing something else at the same time
for someone that uploads daily
is it to me it just sounds like a
nightmare you know when you get a you
when you become a big youtuber you get
all these amazing offers right
who would not want to go on a tour right
it seems insane to not want to go on but
for someone
in my position i know that if i go on a
tour
it's just going to stress me out and
i've learned to say no to things
even though they're incredible
opportunities which seems very egotistic
and
ungrateful but i just know it's
important for my mental health to
to say no to stuff what's the next gun
play you'll be working on
boy i'm super excited i got a new uh
perfect grade i'm gonna be working on
and it's gonna i'm gonna paint it i'm
not gonna say what i'm gonna paint it as
yet but i'm super excited for it i might
live stream it i always say i'm gonna
live stream stuff and then i never do
the thing is like even the same with the
book club do i need to monetize
every single thing in my life am i
really that youtuber
yes yes i am was there ever a point
where you thought the content you made
wasn't what you wanted
to do but the opportunity was just too
good to miss yes this q a video
how do your parents feel about you being
a successful youtuber
are they proud are they disappointed
they're super proud they're definitely
very proud but it did take them a while
to
accept the fact that i wasn't going back
to school
but no they're thrilled they're very
proud and i'm happy
i'm lucky to have such supportive
parents what are your
serious opinions on t-series do you
think it's unfair
that a corporation like t-series is
surpassing you
as an indie youtuber does it make you
feel bad
it's already a heated subject now that a
company
is taking over based on a name the
youtuber you're right
uh and then you know everyone is going
on the
rant about oh youtube is not really
becoming youtube and
uh it's never gonna be the same now i
think if uh
i don't really care about t series i i
genuinely don't but
i think if youtube does shift in a way
where it does feel more corporate
there are something else will take its
place i think people enjoy this
connection so much
i think something else will just show up
if if it feels too corporate
i think what bothers me more than uh
things becoming too corporate is
youtubers shelling corporates
if you know does that make sense
youtubers just buying into
this image that companies want them to
be
for the sake of being lifted up by them
i mean it's
it's a great business move and i i
totally understand why anyone would do
it
but to me uh it's inauthentic and like
we i talked about earlier about
authenticity
i think um that's what i enjoy watching
youtubers for
for being authentic not them being an
image of what they
think someone else wants them to be if
youtube becomes
youtube rewind last one i know
that that bothers me more are you
working on new business ideas after
rebel mode
uh no
f that completely biggest mistake of my
life i mean i
i've learned so much from it don't get
me wrong uh
but uh no screw that
it's like i already have a full-time job
i don't need another full-time job
can you tell me about the story of your
rolex
submariner what do you mean i don't have
ever okay
fine i bought it because you know i
proposed to mars yeah
and she got all this fancy ring and i'm
like this is not fair
what do i get don't i get anything and
people always said well if you're gonna
buy
a nice watch you should buy it for a
good reason and i'm like well i'm not
gonna get a better reason than
uh my proposal so i did buy
a nice watch and it kind of changed my
opinion on uh
i know it's so annoying everything has
to be philosophical but it's nice to
have something that will last your
lifetime
you know previously i didn't look at it
that way but you have your phone
that constantly needs to be charged and
you have i don't know
all these accessories and items that are
always going to be expendable but it's
nice to have
one item that is always going to be
there uh no matter what
your thoughts on buddhism yeah
i really wanted to make a video on
buddhism it's really been on my mind
every single day since i read that book
that i reviewed a few months ago it's
really changed my outlook on so many
things
and it's really helped me a lot as well
i think to become a more positive and
better person
uh not that it's a self-help book but
like i said i do want to talk about it
but at the same time
that feels like i'm preaching or
something like that and that's just
obnoxious so
oh favorite haru haruki murakami book
norwegian wood i'm reading uh killing
commendatory right now it's
uh it's okay if you guys haven't read
anything in a while
i definitely recommend murakami because
it's very comfy
easy to read type of literature and then
with this somewhat deeper meaning as
well so i think
definitely pick up murakami anything
from
him if you want to read uh a good book
and you're not used to reading when will
he do a 5 weird stuff online never
it feels like everyone else took over
those type of shows after i did it
i've seen other channels do those type
of videos and it's just
it doesn't feel like my thing anymore
your current take on the shane dawson
series
on jake paul now that it's over i feel
for jake i really do i feel
i feel really bad for him uh i think
most people that watch it maybe feel bad
for
for him i remember you know the drama
between him and
his brother it wasn't really obvious but
i remember the video where
logan you know was staging that he was
making out with his ex and i just
thought that was the weirdest thing ever
and that's when i realized
you know everyone hate hated jake during
that period i remember
and people people didn't know that logan
was a
logan admitted being a sociopath didn't
he
why is someone talking about that i just
thought it was so cringy how he was
staging
making out with his girlfriend and i
guess a lot of people thought it was
cool so they were like yeah logan is
really awesome and i'm like
no he isn't i guess you know at least
you know i may not
stan jake paul but at least i understand
jake paul i stole that joke from someone
else teach us
about the art of apologizing you seem to
know a lot because of
well your track record but for real
though
give insight on how you deal with
controversy
it's funny how you say that i was
planning to make a video uh where i rate
uh other people's apologies
i thought that might be funny including
my own do you still enjoy making youtube
videos
or i really really do i genuinely do
have you ever
will you ever do a charity thing again
yeah i really want to do a charity
again i just wanted to feel something
that i'm actually
passionate about and i wanted to do it
in a way that feels
interesting as well i think the whole
format of just playing video games and
asking for a donation is kind of tired
and i don't really want to do that
what's your favorite non-anime show
me and marcia love tara's house it's on
netflix it's so good
it's kind of like the concept of big
brother like a bunch of japanese people
living in the same house
but they're free to roam around and do
whatever outside go on dates and whatnot
and what makes it interesting is that
they can leave at any time so usually
you follow someone's story maybe they're
there for romance or for
their job or anything like that and then
when they're done with that they leave
so a new character enter and it's really
nice to see
uh follow these people
young people following their dreams or
whatever their goals are
it's a really good show it takes a while
to get into because it takes a while to
get
you know learn uh care about the people
but it once you do it it's very
impactful
was that it that was it i did it
cool guys i see you guys in three years
it's weird q a is those type of videos
that people enjoy but i don't
i feel like it's so lame uh so i hope
this was alright i feel like i have to
apologize
sorry i'm literally just doing this
because it's martial's birthday today
and i i wanted to just to finish off a
video quickly
leave a like if you enjoyed i want more
q a's every like will shorten
the q a with a year of the next one
we got two days left for the march one
day left on the march so this is your
last chance
if you want to pick it up and that's it
for me for now see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
you